ich fotografiere meine klasse
ich fotografiere meine klasse die klasse
wird fotografiert
die klasse wird fotografiert
mein auto wert repariert mein auto wert
repariert mein auto wert von der
mechanikerin repariert mein auto wird
von der mechanikerin repariert
was
lehrer lenny erklärt grammatik verstehen
hallo zusammen
ich bin lehrer leni heute lernen wir das
passiv ich fotografiere meine klasse
meine klasse wert fotografiert
im passiven satz benutzt man das werk
mit dem hilfswerk werden und dem partie
zib2
sehen
wir uns einige beispiele an
die
die polizei verfolgt ein auto die
polizei verfolgt ein auto
er wird verfolgt er wird verfolgt
er wird von der polizei verfolgt er wird
von der polizei verfolgt
der 8
operiert den patienten der arzt operiert
den patienten der patient wert operiert
der patient wert operiert
der patient wird vom arzt operiert der
patient wert vom arzt operiert
die kellnerin bringt das essen
die kellnerin bringt das essen das essen
wert gebracht
das essen wert gebracht
das essen wert von der kellnerin
[Musik]
gebracht das es wert von der kellnerin
gebracht
die maschine produziert produkte die
maschine produziert produkte
produkte werden produziert produkte
werden produziert produkte werden von
der maschine produziert produkte werden
von der maschine produziert
sie überwacht den prozess sie überwacht
den prozess
der prozess wird überwacht
der prozess wert überwacht
der prozess wert von ihr überwacht
sie malen die bilder
die bilder werden gemalt die bilder
werden gemalt die bilder werden von
ihnen gemalt die bilder werden von ihnen
gemalt
er putzt den boden
er schützt den boden
der bodenwert geputzt
der boden wird geputzt
der bodenwert von ihm geputzt
der bodenwert von ihm
so funktioniert das passiv im präsens
sehen wir uns nun das passiv im
präteritum an
ich
fotografierte meine klasse meine klasse
wurde fotografiert
im präteritum steht das verb werden im
präteritum wir sehen uns wieder einige
beispiele an
si
er forscht den neuen mond sie erforscht
den neuen mond der mond wert erforscht
der mond wert erforscht
dr
und wurde erforscht
der mond wurde erforscht die polizei
verhaftet den dieb die polizei
verhaftete den dieb der dieb wird
verhaftet
der dieb wird verhaftet
der dieb wurde verhaftet
der dieb wurde von der polizei verhaftet
der arzt untersucht
im mrt der arzt untersucht
im mrt er wert im mrt untersucht er wert
im mrt untersucht
er wurde im mrt untersucht wurde
der arzt reanimiert ihm der arzt
reanimiert
er wehrt reanimiert er wird reanimiert
er wird vom arzt reanimiert
er wurde reanimiert
so funktioniert das passiv im präteritum
es gibt noch das zustands passiv
das zustands passiv beschreibt den
zustand eine sache oder person
das haus ist gebaut
das zustand
passiv bilden wir mit dem wert sein und
dem partizip perfekt
wir sehen uns wieder einige beispiele an
das geschäft ist geöffnet
das haus ist gebaut
das auto ist vollgetankt das auto ist
vollgetankt
das handy ist geladen
so funktioniert das zustands passiv im
präsens
sehen wir uns das zustands passiv im
präteritum an
das haus war gebaut
das verb sein steht jetzt im präteritum
wir sehen uns wieder einige beispiele an
das geschäft war geöffnet
das haus war gebaut
das auto war
vollgetankt das auto war voll getankt
das handy war geladen
das waren die wichtigsten passiv formen
tschüss zusammen
[Musik]